un bâtiment qui n'existera plus cet
immeuble va faire place à une ouverture
pour rentrer dans les petits prêts à
elancourt 68 logements vont être
détruits le quartier date des années
1980 il s'agira de transformation des
démolitions d'accord mais aussi des
transformations de grands logements
verts des plus petits logements et de la
création du lot ce qu'on appelle du
logement intermédiaire c'est-à-dire
quelques pavillons et aussi des petits
immeubles collectifs de manière à
diversifier l'offre de logement un
projet à plus de 50 millions d'euros un
appui financier est apportée par le
département dans le cadre de priori
flynn le programme de relance et
d'intervention pour l'offre
résidentielle
les bailleurs la ville et saint quentin
en yvelines complète le projet on a une
volonté là d'apporter d'ouvrir va boire
le quartier sur les autres secteurs
comme les horizons par exemple ou alors
le centre d cette mare et puis de créer
de nouvelles circulations douces de
renouveler tous les flux que ce soit
pied tonéo go vélo et puis aussi
automobile pourquoi pas le quartier des
petits traitance centrale est important
d'y apporter une touche bien
particulière des familles seront
relogées en 2022 2023 première étape des
travaux en 2024 la concertation auprès
des habitants se tient jusqu'au 17
décembre prochain le projet pourrait se
tenir jusqu'en 2028